so
it was after college that the spells
became both a burden and a blessing
not being able to pull myself out of the
paralysis one night
i let go
and felt myself slowly rising out of my
body
i had come through the terror part
and felt a wonderful peaceful bliss as i
rose out of my body and floated up
i would feel that the surfaces of
various objects were covered by a film
of fuzz or the down in a pillow
it could also be described as cotton
candy or spider webs
sometimes the webs and fuzz can get very
lush as when i reach down to pick up
something that has fallen underneath my
desk and my hand feels as if it has
become submerged in a huge pile of this
stuff
but when i try to scoop up that pile i
feel nothing and yet i feel that i have
a large amount of this stuff in my hands
i start to see what you might see on the
dash of your car at night
except the numbers begin spinning more
and more rapidly
after about 20 seconds the numbers begin
to disintegrate and the odometer itself
falls apart
and gradually disappears
once i was competing in the ironman
triathlon in hawaii i was not having a
good race i was overwhelmed and
dehydrated miserable
three miles into the marathon portion of
the race i saw my wife and mom standing
on the side of the road i ran over to
them to say that i would be late to the
finish line
but when i reached them and began
telling my tale of woe
two complete strangers who did not even
remotely resemble my wife and my mother
were looking back at me
what a great house it's great to have
you all here welcome to science and
story i am john huckenberry
science and story
they certainly do go together
because what is science but the story of
not boy meets girl but cause meets
effect
and then the story of our discoveries
and learning about
the reality of the world around us and
then of course science is the story of
what we do with those discoveries and
what we do with that understanding and
how that understanding
changes us
and tonight
we're going to explore a little bit this
notion of hallucinations and there's a
really young crowd here
i hesitate to say don't try this at home
but i suspect many of you have
already
oh well
um
be that as it may let me tell you a
little
hallucination story here in this hallway
where we might actually get a glimpse of
abraham lincoln if we're lucky
um
all of new york this week is something
of a hallucination my neighborhood looks
like gaza
and
we're experiencing a sense of
perceptual distortion i think from our
encounters with the
natural world this week
but let me tell you about a young fellow
who's studying mathematics at the
university of chicago several decades
ago who had a
uh predisposition for uh psilocybin
mushrooms
in the course of his mathematical
studies and was on a trip hitchhiking
across the country and got in a car with
some
lovely individuals who said look we're
driving straight through
to massachusetts and here
we've got these amphetamines that are
keeping us awake why don't you stay
awake with us i got in the back seat of
the car we took these strange pills alas
the uh
pills did not
do what they were supposed to for the
driver
and at a certain point in pennsylvania
she drove off the road and went down a
200-foot embankment i was in the
backseat of that car
and when i came to consciousness a few
moments after the car reached the bottom
of the hill
i realized that i was probably paralyzed
for life
and was staring through
the shattered windshield of a chevrolet
nova up at a beautiful blue sky
bleeding from a skull fracture and a
serious uh set of internal injuries and
the blood from the injuries to my head
were seeping into the area around my
eyes so that my eyes were turning
completely red and i was looking
at the world through this
strange
blood filter and i could see clearly and
all of a sudden as i looked through this
shattered windshield
i could see not the sky anymore but i
could see
this
automobile and there was this
sad
young man in that
car and and there were
ambulance people trying to saw this car
it happened i looked down and i went oh
that's a terrible situation there
what's going on i hope that fellow's all
right and i watched for a while and it
was terribly noisy and
i was feeling very relieved that i was
far away from that mess and i stared at
it for a while and all of a sudden
the view
began to get a little dark
and
everything sort of
rushed like the sound of a train and all
of a sudden
i realized that i was the person in that
car and that they had in fact managed to
saw the roof off of the car and pulled
me to safety i lost consciousness at
that point and woke up in a recovery
room in a hospital
days later so what happened what was
going on in my brain during this
event because i remember it vividly
vividly and can recall precisely what i
was looking at from down
in the trees
down on what was happening to me
something i couldn't possibly have
actually seen because i was in the
middle of it all was it just some
spiritual kind of whoa
intense experience or did it reveal
something fundamental about the
organization of the brain
that's what we're going to explore
tonight and we certainly have as you've
already heard
the best person on planet earth to help
explore it with us
he's an author a scholar a doctor
clinician
professor
and in many ways the preeminent
storyteller of the brain
please welcome doctor professor
friend
oliver sacks
so we want to remind you to uh tweet
at uh ask oliver hashtag ask oliver and
uh as tracy mentioned there are many
ways for you to be involved in this uh
conversation and we'll have some of your
questions later i've got uh actual
connection to the
internet here i believe yes it's working
so i will get your questions and towards
the end of this session
uh we'll hear from you directly
welcome
i feel welcome and rather scared
yeah
this this concert sold out in a couple
of hours so as we were saying backstage
you're sort of the justin bieber of uh
neurologists
that's a good position to be it's a good
brand i'd say
let's let's start with a very basic
question what do we think
a hallucination
is in the mind and as a researcher and
scientist
what
are we discovering is going on in the
brain when a hallucination happens
well a hallucination
usually comes as a sudden apparition
visual a sight a sound a smell it's out
there it seems absolutely real
when it's very startled because one
hasn't willed this thing one hasn't
imagined
the vision
one has no control over it
and
you think it's real
and but other people don't agree with
you
and then
perhaps at that point you realize it
must be a hallucination
and that part of your brain has gone on
automatic
and
and it's out of your hands
but the
the first real hallucination
is a is very startling and very
frightening
and
often rather wonderful
and we'll explore that full range from
frightening to wonderful in our
conversation this evening
the idea of hallucinations goes back a
long way
in
human history and in medical history
describe a little bit of the
change in
approach to what we think hallucinations
are
down through medical history
um
well up to about 1800 there were
anyone was allowed to have visions or to
hear voices
they were assumed to have some
external
spiritual origin
gods demons the muses ancestors the dead
and
around two centuries ago
the business became medicalized and
hallucinations were seen as a disorder
of the brain
probably
um
associated with madness but then that
connection was immediately contested
although i think it's still a strong one
in the public mind and the medical mind
that hallucinations are a portent
of something
bad or mad
happening
you mentioned a moment ago that the the
experience of a hallucination
originates in
in the part of the brain that that is
associated with
actual real events it's not an imagined
experience it's more like a real
experience what what do you mean exactly
um well the
parts of the brain
use in perception and recognition are
hijacked
by
the hallucinatory process
and what goes on in your
visual cortex or your auditory brain
is
is physiologically almost
indistinguishable from
actually
seeing or hearing something
um you don't get that sort of activation
with imagining
you only get it with hallucinations so
hallucination is a form of perception
and light perception what you
hallucinate is is out there
it startles you
you you look around you
it's and it's it often has a
a detail
uh which which is far greater than that
of any imagery
and um
and who don't know where it comes from
and what we're looking at here are some
fmri images where we've just in the last
uh half decade or so been able to
test and show the state of the mind
imagining something
having a hallucination
and actually seeing something and they
are three distinct states
um i i can't see the images behind me
but but they are indeed distinct
and um
the
you're not hallucinating
um and um
one can almost do a sort of mind reading
uh perhaps when someone is in an fmri a
functional brain imaging you might say
to the mum
are you hallucinating faces
they say yeah yeah how did you know you
say you know because a particular area
so-called fusiform face area
is become
hyperactive
at the back of the back of the brain on
one side
and if they say they're seeing
letters or text or musical notation you
can you can also guess that so um
so so hallucinations are
an immediate expression of brain
activity from very simple levels like um
geometrical patterns
to um see in heaven
and we'll talk about some specific
clinical examples of uh hallucinations
in just a moment that both you've
observed directly and through uh
individuals and cases that you're
familiar with but
part of what you describe in this book
is a brain that functions like a
reality synthesizer that what's
happening in a
in a hallucination
is so close to reality it's not a dream
state at all
um
can
can this be called dysfunctional in
other words this is what the brain is
supposed to do yet we associate
hallucinations with
dysfunction
um
i think that's too narrower term
and
there are for example
bereavement hallucinations
these especially occur
if people have been happily married for
half a century or whatever and if the
husband or wife dies
there's a 50 chance
that the remaining spouse will see them
or hear them
and this sort of hallucination is not
frightening it's often very comforting
um
it's it seems to be part of the mourning
process
and it really you know a sudden whole
has been left in one's life
and this helps helps it to heal over so
there i would say the hallucination is
highly adaptive and not dysfunctional
in in the case of a bereavement
hallucination
how
does the brain cross over from very
powerful memory and almost nostalgic
experience of a lost loved one to
literally
experiencing their presence in a
hallucinatory way
um well there's certainly a leap
because the most vivid imagination
uh
um can't match the faintest
hallucination
we
one can see the leap
if someone is in
functional functional brain imager
but
why it occurs and why it's more likely
to occur in some people but one knows
for example that it can be
induced by hypnosis
and
if you
if you ask someone to
imagine a scene or for example
to imagine a drum with vertical stripes
going around
they say yes i'm imagining it but their
eyes won't move
but if you can hypnotize them and they
hallucinate it then the eyes keep
jerking as they would in reality
and um
and the two things are quite separate
and yet one can leap from one to the
other
that's amazing let's talk about some of
the classical uh cases
where hallucinations are associated with
particular
syndromes um we can begin i suppose with
epilepsy which has a long long history
it was originally viewed as the sacred
disorder
part of connection with god you've sort
of alluded to that before um what
happens in epilepsy and what are the
hallucinatory consequences that you're
familiar with
um
well um
hippocrates wrote about it he accepted
the the term sacred disease but
immediately said there's nothing sacred
about it it has a natural cause
although he conceded that the visions
and voices which one might have with the
seizure might
seem to have
a divine or a demonic origin
an epilepsy is a sudden explosive firing
of part of the brain
of a knot of cells
and
what happens depends on where the knot
is
sometimes it may cause a sudden
jerk
sometimes it may cause a sensation
epilepsy in primitive parts of the
visual brain would just um
give one pattern so the auditory parts
are hiss
but as you go up to higher and higher
levels
you can have so-called ecstatic seizures
um where um
i suppose it don't look so eager these
are pretty rare
um
and it's concert sold out in a few hours
okay and i can't tell you how
right
but in so-called ecstatic seizures
um
uh dostoevsky had these and described
them beautifully and gave them to many
of his characters but there will be a
sudden sense of
of bliss of rapture
and um
a feeling perhaps that one has been
transported
to heaven
or that one is um
there is nearly always a
some
either a mystical or religious or a
sexual
mint to ecstatic hallucinations
and if they have a
and even people who've had no
disposition to mystical or religious
thinking apparently before
may be converted
by these experiences
and converted repeatedly there was one
neurologist
geschwind who was very interested in
this and he spoke of one of his patients
as a
a girl in her twenties
now on her fifth
religion
um but um
uh
i mean there are
many many paths to religion
including purely intellectual paths but
um
to have a sense of
overwhelming reality
a celestial reality a supernatural
reality and a seizure
demands
um
quite a
a
tough skepticism to resist
so you can study
to be a priest or you can take the uh
hallucinatory shortcut
to god right yeah right
let's talk about um
what happens at the onset
of the seizure
and some of the
states in the brain that precede the
actual seizure which also relates to
some of the work that you've done on
migraines where you'll have an aura or a
very particular sense of of
visual hallucinations that then precede
a state
that in the case of a seizure
really sort of shuts the person down
often causing them to lose consciousness
in the case of migraines then a
prolonged period of dysfunctional pain
occurs but this aura period is
fascinating to me
yeah well the um
the the aura is
is the most interesting and it's not
necessarily followed by
a headache
or or a convulsion one could have
isolated ors
and really these are the best things to
have
um
for example i
i've had visual migraines
since i was three or four years old but
i've almost never had a headache
in the visual migraine there's a sudden
explosion of light
near what i'm looking at and this
expands it has a zigzag border and a
scintillates
and uh
and it takes
a rather constant for me while the
constant 17 or 18 minutes to go from the
center to the side
you can have more complex things with
migraine
siri huster the novelist
has written about this and how she
herself on one occasion
saw a little
pink man
and his ox about six inches high
and she describes how she looked at them
tenderly they weren't frightening
and then they disappeared after a few
minutes and so that's the so-called
lilliputian hallucination
they're quite common and one wonders you
know whether some of our notions of
imps and elves and sprites and little
little green men
you know may
may be suggested by this
but there's a clinical pattern of little
little dudes
um there is
um
lilliputian vision
has a specific physiological basis
but the sort of little people one sees
is going to depend on one's
one's own interest in one's culture so
that maybe if you're irish you will see
leprechauns
if you're norwegian you will see trolls
some troll seers out there
apparently um
you know one of the things that you get
from reading this book and really from
the whole body of your work is just
what the brain is capable of
uh
you know it makes you feel that there's
just a whole lot going on in the brain
that we don't unless we
have some of these syndromes that you
describe uh we don't really experience
one of the most amazing stories in this
book is about i believe it's something
called anton syndrome it was described
anyway in the 1800s
a person who is blind
insists that they can see
and that their brain is creating an
experience that is so powerfully visual
to them that they argue with people who
know that they're blind and insist that
the blindness doesn't exist at all
how does that work
well um
this is a sort of situation which
i've encountered a lot working in old
age homes
where i may see
elderly people who
who are completely intact mentally but
who have impaired
vision or hearing
a good proportion something like 15
of those with visual impairment may get
elaborate hallucinations of animals and
people and landscapes
and probably 80 percent of them
get simple hallucinations of geometric
patterns
incidentally i'm one of those 80 myself
are you the animals or the geometric
patterns only geometric patterns
it's enough
i i see them all the time
they're all over the ceiling
um and and i ignore them as i ignore the
tinnitus the hissing in my ear which is
sort of partly um a sort of order to
equivalent though the commonest
hallucination for people as they become
deaf are
is hearing music
the
now i think you you've mentioned
something
rather rare
uh which was not quite
well i i i i let me distinguish two
things
the um
i start the book by describing how i was
called to a nursing home they said they
had an old lady in her 90s
and she suddenly started seeing things
and they didn't know if she was going
crazy or had a stroke
could i come along
and i saw the old lady
she was a very vigorous old lady
very sane
very intelligent
and very puzzled
and somewhat frightened
she said she'd been blind for five years
but now she's seeing things
i said but what sort of things
and she said people
in eastern dresses
walking in rows
and she described she saw animals she
saw horses
she saw a snowstorm
she saw a horrible face
horrible because the face was distorted
and partly dismembered
um
and she was afraid that she was going
mad or had some neurological catastrophe
i examined her i couldn't find anything
the matter with her nervous system she
wasn't on any medications which could
produce things so i said i know i think
i know what you have
uh
and
i said i think this is the brain
reacting
to to your blindness to loss of visual
input
and the brain is always at work
24 hours a day
and it's always processing things and if
it can't process information from your
eyes it'll go down into memory or
imagination
take
whatever and then scramble it all up and
and give you people an eastern dress or
horses or snow storms or whatever
and i said this was described right back
in the 18th century this is charles
bonnet syndrome
and she was
greatly relieved and actually rather
pleased that her condition had a name
she said
she said tell the nurses that that i
have
charles bonnet syndrome
and then she said who was this charles
bonney
did he have it himself
actually he didn't at the time he wrote
about it his grandfather did he did have
it later
um
but that's the common situation there is
another
very rare situation which i only touch
on
in the book
where
usually from a stroke people can become
suddenly totally blind
and yet
they
don't know it
they insist that they can see
and they will
blunder into things and find other
explanations
and that is
that is a very mysterious sort of
whether one should even call that
hallucination or whether it's a sort of
delusion or confabulation
but on the whole i'm i'm sticking more
to the
the old lady who sees
people in eastern dress
and and thank you for for sticking with
that that's for sure because those are
the most entertaining
of the hallucinations and really sort of
cause us to think more about just
the potential and the complexity of the
brain itself let's talk just briefly
about
uh there are lots of hallucinations you
sort of alluded to them that aren't
visual at all that conjure up other
sensations
tactile hallucinations smell
hallucinations these sorts of things
what have you studied yeah um
smell hallucinations are often the often
form the or
to certain epileptic seizures
but smell hallucinations are quite
common because something like
five percent of the population
lose their sense of smell partly or
wholly either following an infection
sometimes a head injury and they then
tend to hallucinate smells as the blind
hallucinate visions
and
the
it may be impossible for the person to
describe the smell because the smell be
maybe unlike anything in their
experience or anything they could
imagine
and
similarly if people may hallucinate a
color
they've never seen and they can't
imagine
and one realizes that the repertoire of
what the brain can do is much larger
than
than what one actually has in the world
um
uh people who
hallucinate colors
they've never seen sometimes call them
martian colors
since you mentioned um color
dr sacks would you care to share your
story of discovering the color indigo
in your own uh
research into
inducing
hallucinations
oh
you come by this rightly i mean you you
have had
many hallucinatory experiences some of
which were an accidental consequence of
substances that you were working with
and others more deliberate yeah um
well there were there were many
different motives
um and it was all it was all a long time
ago
which was uh
um was all between 63 and 67 but but
certainly i'm one of them
um i'd i'd been puzzling about
indigo indigo was um inserted into the
spectrum by newton
so was orange he felt there should be
seven colors as the seven notes in the
musical scale
but it seemed to me that no two people
agreed as to what indigo was like
and it was in fact felt that the pigment
derived from the indigo plant was was
not really indigo
and i
decided i wanted to see
um i couldn't imagine it but i thought i
might be able to hallucinate it
so i built a sort of pharmacological
launch pad
now
that that's different from controlled
substance okay pharmacological launch
pad i love that that's uh this is a
writer here this is what we've got so
there was also a base of amphetamine
um and then some lsd and a little a
little cannabis on top
so i'll
i'll take uh
a shot of amphetamine with a a an lsd
chaser and a spot of cannabis
and that gets you
um well it got me fairly pickled
i think stoned is the right word
anyhow when
when i felt ready i said i want to see
indigo
now
and
as if
thrown by a paintbrush
a trembling
pear-shaped blob
of of the most wonderful color appeared
on the wall
um
indigo
and um it not only seemed you know
wonderfully luminous
but it filled me with a sort of
mystical or almost religious joy i felt
it was numinous as well as luminous
and although i'm an old jewish atheist
i thought
this is the color of heaven
i thought this is the color which jotto
tried to get
but never could
and
maybe this is a color which no longer
exists on the earth and i lend forward
to a sort of ecstasy and it vanished
and
i felt very heartbroken
and in fact for months afterwards
i i would turn over little stones and
things i was looking for indigo
i did experience it once again
and that was when i came to new york in
65
and i went to a concert
in the metropolitan museum of art in the
egyptology gallery
and at the first half of the concert
there was some monteverdi
which
um which transported me
and uh
and in a sort of rapture
i am in the interval i wandered
into the egyptology gallery and saw
there were some lapis lazuli amulets and
so forth and some of them were indigo
i thought thank god it exists in the
world
but in the second half of the concert i
i didn't like the music much i became a
little bored and irritable but i thought
i can i can
go and get a sip of indigo
but when i went back uh the lapis lazuli
was just blue and move and puse and
and i've never seen indigo again
um
but that showed a cry
i know well well i did
um
looking looking for indigo could have
been the title of this book i suppose
yeah
in a uh
pharmacological launch pad induced uh
hallucination
is there some connection between the
imagination and the hallucination itself
in the sense that you're describing
where you've actually conjured something
which is more like imagination than
hallucination um well i i am
i i knew it would have to be a blue
of some sort
and so i predetermined it i didn't say i
want to see indigo and then see a
splotch of orange
um so i played a part but then it it
took this leap
helped by the launch pad from from
imagination
uh to hallucination
incidentally i'm i'm not recommending
the experience
um
although if you can get it from music or
from falling in love or for meditation
um
or from scenery
that's
that's really a much better way
i am
i'm glad i survived my drug period
many of my friends didn't
let's talk a little bit about um what
questions about
and observations
of hallucinations have taught you
about the brain and how it actually
works
what have they revealed they're they're
a bit of a window into the larger
organization of the brain
um
well um
the very
fact that hallucinations exist
shows that there can be a mode of
consciousness and a mode of perception
quite unlike
dream or fantasy or imagination
and
and it may
make certain things available which
which imagination
can't can't do
um
this has been felt by
some writers and
poets certainly in the early 19th
century
coleridge and baudelaire and edgar allan
poe and you know they were they were all
taking something
um
poe was raised as a child
uh his mother
gave him
gin soaked bread to keep him from crying
so i think he started very early po
yeah which isn't necessarily a
hallucinogen but
you know i i miss something what what
was
who was given what oh edgar allan poe
as a baby by his mother was given gin
soaked bread yes
to calm him down yeah pre-tylenol i
guess
it's like um
in pygmalion gin was mother's milk to
her
yeah no no in the 19th century babies
were often calmed very effectively by
gin
but um
but um
when he grew up
uh
he and and his
and others tended to take opium of one
sort and another
um
there's a wonderful book called opium
and the romantic imagination
although this is really opium and
romantic hallucination
the
but one
realizes in a way how
narrow
um
ordinary consciousness is
and
and necessarily so
if one is going to function in the world
if there's a huge enhancement of
perception
or
or things which are not there
you can't function all that well
in fact civilization requires a
narrowness of consciousness so that we
can all be on the same page enough
to function in society as it seems to me
um
william james talks about this in the
varieties of religious experience he
he took nitrous oxide laughing gas
so-called except it didn't make him
laugh it transported him into other
forms of consciousness and he insisted
that there are many other forms of
consciousness outside the rational
consciousness
and um
and that they all have their value
do you believe that
yes
um and on that note
but um
but um
but the
but it really depends
uh
how one
integrates or how one employs another
form of consciousness
it
but certainly i think another form of
consciousness is
involved in
you know in creating art
and in scientific discovery
and sometimes there are
um
there are patent
hallucinations
wallace
conceived his theory of natural
selection
in a high fever for malaria
and
some
some
painters have had
visions and fifa and so forth which uh
piranesi was said to have
visualized his extraordinary prisons and
fortresses also an attack of
with an attack of malaria
but
the
the great chemist kekule
when he was on a bus
a london bus in the 1850s
fell into a state which i think many of
us know it's just before sleep
when you can start seeing things
and quickly
saw
snakes devouring their own tails but for
him
this was a symbol
of the
hexagonal structure of benzene
and allowed him to found
really organic structural chemistry i
mean he's standing in line for gasoline
here in new york because of some clown
on a london bus who hallucinated snakes
and
all right so uh questions from you and
uh there are microphones and uh people
who will help you to
uh deliver your question to us and for
you
watching the live stream i have
questions here to ask my last question
to you is how different is this book
from what timothy leary and alan watts
wrote about
in the 1960s and 70s about the
hallucinatory experience um well i think
they were
somewhat evangelical
which i'm not
um
it's um
i mean my purposes is
is to describe
all the varieties i can think of
with with one exception i hardly touch
schizophrenic hallucinations i think
that needs a different sort of book
and whether i will ever write that i i
don't know but i think um
uh
um hallucination is
is feared is misrepresented people can
agonize
for years um
never mentioning that they hallucinate i
want to open the subject up
um
and
so that so that people don't have to
have burning secrets
and on the whole they'll be reassured
because hallucinations tend to be benign
there are 100 times more benign
hallucinations than malignant ones so
share your hallucinations you're among
friends here
at the cooper union here's a question
from one of our online viewers is there
an evolutionary advantage to being able
to hallucinate or is it just a byproduct
of having a brain
that's a very good question
well it certainly
is a byproduct
or can be considered as a byproduct
and
but whether but it can also be
considered
i think sometimes as having adaptive use
um
for example um
well one
blind man who wrote to me about his
hallucinations he imagines his eyes
saying to him
we know blindness is no fun
so we've invented this small syndrome
as a coder to your site at life
it's not much but it's the best we could
do
and um they're quite a lot of
um
well whether
nature thought of this or whether this
is just a human use
but i think
i think bereavement hallucinations are
are adaptive
and after very terrifying
situations can cause flashbacks
and this can happen in in animals as
well
when pavlov pavlos labardi full of dogs
and had a flood in 1924 the dogs watched
as the water rose and escaped at the
last moment and after that most of those
dogs were were haunted by
by water they had sort of
post-stress traumatic syndromes
and however
this
would teach them to avoid anything
dangerous with regard to water
i so sometimes it's a byproduct and
i mean certainly the brain
is able to produce hallucinations of
every sort
and maybe it depends what use has made
of it i love this idea that the brain
develops its own
mental prosthetics to deal with things
like blindness and deafness question out
here
hello dr sacks thank you very much for
coming in today um i was wondering as
uh we continue to map
different sensations and perceptions to
different parts of the brain like face
recognition being mapped to the fusiform
gyrus do you think that eventually we'll
develop technology that will be able to
trigger certain perceptions or
sensations on command
i'm just trying to improve on your
pharmacological launch pad
i
i suspect
we will
and this will raise
um
all sorts of problems ethical and
otherwise
um
we're we're getting rather close to the
verge of this even now
but um in in a simple way right back in
the 1960s it was possible to insert
electrodes into the so-called reward
centers in rats brains
and
if they pressed a lever this would give
them a little shock
um
which was probably a bit like an orgasm
and anyhow the rats who did this would
keep pressing the lever they would not
eat they would not sleep they would
press the lever till they died
and
so that it was
basically you're describing an early
form of twitter
here's a question from uh uh from
twitter
i'm sorry i i i want to
go back to to an earlier thing and i'm
like that that's why i have footnotes
and whatnot um i've i was very struck
with my
awakenings patients
but i only learned this after i had got
to know them well
that most of them had been hallucinators
for decades
before they had eldopa
and their hallucinations were entirely
pleasant friendly sociable i think they
hallucinated the world
uh which was denied them
and that that was the experience of
awakenings of course the movie were
familiar with and that that was the
treatment of eldopa and that was
parkinson's like yes yeah a parkinson's
plus i mean i mean many of them were
absolutely frozen
but there
and many of them had been um abandoned
by relatives and family and and were
in backboards of hospitals
but they um
i think they um
their brains
fed them visions and feelings and
emotions which really kept them going
and which were a substitute for life
one might say one shouldn't have
substitutes but these people
had uh you know had no choice
but the brain
finds an adaptive quality to creating
these visual substitutions and
alternative realities and that that
seems to be some structural feature of
how the brain is organized is what
you're saying um we've got questions out
oh
neil
mister how you doing dr tyson okay
john
oliver i'm sorry
yeah the stars are out tonight
uh
uh
oliver i'm curious
we could imagine a future of
neuroscience which we all know is
advancing rapidly
i can imagine a day perhaps where they
can go into your brain and
snip a neurosynaptic connection
that would end all hallucinations
let's imagine that for the moment
if we could do that should we
and if you had that option
would you
and if it were available
do you imagine a sort of an ethical line
beyond which we should not alter
people's behavior because it is a
product of the mores of the day
that could change over the decades
deep deep question and uh and a question
which is becoming
technologically possible it's no longer
just a fantasy
um
a
particular form of this
relates to
unpleasant traumatic memories
um
there may be chemical ways
of
of reducing these
which has been especially suggested for
people with post-traumatic stress
syndrome
um
and uh
would this be a benefit or are we
are we meddling
or to take a much cruder example when
there was a great fashion for
lobotomies and leukotomies in the 1950s
um
was it ethical you know people were
often an intolerable tormenting
obsession and anxiety and they might be
released from this but but should they
be released
um
i am
specifically i think hallucinations are
you know an unusual
rich
um
uh
um a rich expression of the brain's
activity
um
and we'd be poor without them
you described in the book some of these
precise dilemmas in the way epileptics
were treated in the sense that lesions
were so localized that a snip was nearly
possible in some cases was there an
ethical consideration in those
cases uh
yes
specifically actually people with
ecstatic hallucination ecstatic seizures
would not take their medication and they
would also they would also learn ways of
stimulating these
um
but um
i
i i can't answer your question neil but
but the next the next 50 years will
quickly from an email that we just
received could you comment on the
alteration of time perception during
hallucinations
um
yes this may occur
and in the
first book
written about hashish
in um
in the 1840s funny you know there were a
lot of books written about hashish i
guess right yeah
this was written by a physician who was
possibly something of an advocate for it
but he he spoke of the immense
extension of time the subjective
extension so so it might seem to take
forever to walk to the end of a block
in
in a more recent book on the subject the
story is told of two
um potheads
in san francisco lying and lying in the
golden gate park and a jet plane is
going overhead and one of them says man
that that plane took forever
the um
uh
so so so time sensations can certainly
change a lot whether there is any actual
acceleration of thought
um but one might ask this with a
with a dream
i i know i
i have an alarm
at five o'clock with a second alarm at
five past five
i may fall asleep after the first alarm
and dream a lifetime
until i'm woken by the second alarm
and i think it's similar with with
hallucinations
there there are also hallucinations in
the other
direction
i i describe a deplorable
though enjoyable one which i had myself
with with opium
actually morphine
and
in which i appeared
a little spot on my my robe my dressing
gown was on the door as i watched a
little area came to life
and then i saw
myriads of people
apparently two armies assembling
for battle and i realized henry v that's
the hallucination hallucination i
realized i was seeing ashen core
and i somehow i i no longer felt that i
was
in london lying and beard stoned having
shot up some morphine um
i just felt like like a
bodyless observer of this and then it
faded and i i thought well you know that
was an interesting
quarter of an hour
but actually it was 13 hours
and
and that scared me and i never never
tried that again
but
but you can certainly um
there can be prodigious accelerations
and alternate and retardations of time
subjectively
question over here
good evening dr sachs thanks for your
insight and such an interesting topic um
my question is with um with all this
proof
uh the double helix uh discovered and
the psychedelic experience
steve jobs apple computers
uh thousands hundreds of years of
literary works all coming from the
psychedelic experience
and yet it's still demonized
would you say this is an extension of
60's counter culture
a political issue a medical issue
and how will people in society
handle uh having something so close to
them that has such a
wide range of inspiration that is is
clearly being closed off and demonized
what's your opinion you know
sort of political thing or
well first i think i think it's
important to say that
every culture known to us has discovered
plants with psychoactive chemicals
and has usually incorporated these in
some sort of
ceremonial or ritual use
but
and that never seems to get out of hand
or to raise severe
ethical or legal dilemmas
there was a lot of
good research
on lsd and
psilocybin and similar substances
in the
late 50s and the early 60s
but then i think when timothy leary
edau
sort of um
became so evangelistic i think as you
say this
uh
uh there arose a counterculture which
had to be squashed
um
and there was really no good work
on lsd for for 40 years
um
now the atmosphere is changing and some
good and legitimate work
is coming back and perhaps some good and
legitimate the closely supervised
uses
and again political atmospheres are
changing a bit
um
in holland for example
you know any cafe you're liable to be
offered
hash
in in any cafe you go to
um
it has never apparently led to the use
of hard drugs and now apparently sort of
i think
colorado and the state of washington
have decriminalized cannabis
that's our crowd tonight yes indeed
um although it is still a federal
misdemeanor
so i don't know how this will be
resolved although i love that question
it's the first i'd heard that um
the ipad might have been an actual
hallucination i thought i thought jobs
got that from just watching old episodes
of star trek
question here
yes it seems that in all areas of
medicine there have been tremendous
advancements but in neurology and the
study of brain there have been
comparatively not quite as many and
because it is such an intricate subject
where do we go from here and
what's the next understanding in the
brain and for these hallucinations
i'm sorry i missed some of that can you
relay it to me
it's a little bit of an extension on the
the previous question where do we go
from here in in terms of the study of
hallucinations and the brain and
particularly given the technology that
we have for
studying the brain
well
some of the most valuable information
has come from
electrodes implanted in individual nerve
cells
but one could only do this
in a very exceptional
situation namely if someone is being
prepared
for surgery
and has
had their brain exposed
and um and you want to
map things out to make sure that the
surgery doesn't do any harm
um
but uh i think we're going to find
all sorts of um
less intrusive ways
of studying the brain in my new detail
um
with brain imaging you um this is in a
way pretty crude you see an area with a
you know half a billion nerve cells
um
uh
we're just looking at blood flow right i
mean you're looking yes at this stage
we're just looking at blood flow we're
not actually looking at the neuron right
exactly
um
the um
the thought is that the active units in
the cerebral cortex probably consist of
uh somewhere between a hundred and a
thousand nerve cells and that each of
those nerve cells has a thousand to ten
thousand
uh
connections to other cells
and the this is a sort of
hyper astronomical complexity
and
as yet we can't imagine any way of
visualizing this let alone manipulating
it in a delicate way
do you think though do you think though
and and this follows on to this question
as well do you think the
hallucinatory properties of the brain
may someday be accessible to literally
do what hallucinations seem to be trying
to do replace vision to turn the brain
into a
visual simulator that actually comes
close
to imaging reality but creating a
simulation for the person
um
well of course when everyone has virtual
reality of all sorts in a way
hallucinations can be a virtual reality
um i i don't know whether whether you
mean sort of
um
as it were the
the break the the brain and a jar notion
which is being stimulated
more is there a way of of
accessing the hallucinatory capacities
within the brain for someone who is
blind for instance and
generating
the
impulses in the brain that correspond to
what the eyes would produce if they
could function optically that you would
you would generate a hallucination um i
think that should be relatively simple
um
nice
um
something which is rather extraordinary
um
for people who are
born blind and who have never had any
visual experience
um
one can put
a grid of
100 electrodes
on the tongue
and connect it to a video camera so so
that 100 pixels of that are going to the
electrodes
and
the person can hold the camera
and if they do that they start
there's no word for it but it is at
first as if they're seeing with their
tongue but then later it seems to become
a real visual experience
and things like zooming and looming and
perspective and occlusion
come in
and you can also find that the um
that the visual cortex
is is being stimulated so in fact these
people are seeing through entirely
artificial means and bypassing the eyes
and if that can be done
i i would think hallucinations would be
a cinch
there's a tweet hallucinations would be
a cinch question over here
hello
thank you very much dr saks for coming
um i have a question i know that there
are
um
there are people such as yourself who
experience things like migraine auras
and and patterns on the ceiling in a
certain
hallucinatory
day-to-day experience
and i also know that
when people are having more
isolated experiences they experience a
sort of synesthesia of senses
that one might see
sounds or hear colors
and i was wondering what the overlap of
that might be in the brain a synthetic
experience versus a hallucination
because there are people
who are born
into this world who
seek
see sounds or hear colors
for their entire lifetime and that is
their reality and how
so my question is how would that
person's reality differ from another
person's hallucination um
well
synesthesia
as you say is something one
is
born with
it has even been suggested that everyone
every infant has synesthesia in the
first year of life but then that it's
the possibility
is pruned out in the majority of people
synesthesia used to be regarded as very
rare like one and two thousand is now
seen as relatively common about one and
twenty uh particularly common forms
have to do with
seeing colors
as one hears music or when one reads
letters
it's lifelong and it's always the same
for a given person
nabokov in his autobiography mentions
that when he was learning to read he had
colored letters and he felt the colors
were wrong
and he mentioned this to his synesthetic
mother
who agreed that they were wrong but
but the two of them couldn't agree and
didn't agree as to what the colors
should be
and um
the um
but this um
and here there is a
uh a permanent coupling say between
color constructing parts of the brain
and reading parts of the brain or
whatever
in the
with something like lsd hallucination
there may be
improvised
or certain epilepsies that may be
immediate improvised
synesthesias
the
one epileptic patient
spoke of the
smell of green thunder
there's a nice complex
but um
but the epileptic or hallucinatory ones
are unstable
and they go away
and the next time you take it they may
be quite different and so i really think
they're different experiences
um incidentally um
colorblind people
with color synesthesia may also see
colors they've never seen in the world
and martian colors
i'm sensing that you have a
personal relationship with this
synesthesia
hallucination
what's the motivation of your question
it's fascinating uh
i
it's a combination of the way i
perceive things personally and uh
and interest in people who experience it
in a lot more of a in a much more
dramatic fashion like um there's a book
called born on a blue day
about a man named daniel tamet who has a
full spectrum synesthesia so all of his
senses are are combined and i was one
when you were talking about indigo i was
thinking
these colors that you um
you've never seen before
is he seeing colors i've never seen
before how is that
uh overlapping with a hallucinatory
experience listen i i have a question
for you um would you like to be relieved
of your synesthesia
no not at all no
all right
thank you it's not it's not so dramatic
as it is um
been described in in other people's
accounts i think it's just a helpful way
of connecting the dots for me um well
attitudes are very various though
there's some some people love their
synesthesia some hate it and some are
are indifferent but but the question
might be if it were technically possible
would it be right would it be ethical if
people wanted to get rid of their
synesthesia or does one say god made you
synesthetic
and
and
you know you stay that way that's a
great great question it gets back to
neil's point let's get a question here
we're getting towards the end it's
fantastic that all of you are lined up
here we could probably go for a couple
hours i'll rely on my
minders here to shut us down on time but
i'm i'm anxious to hear what people have
to say you're next good evening dr sax
so you've made a distinction between
hallucinations and memories or
imaginations how does that distinction
stem toward dreaming or even lucid
dreaming because when you talked about
summoning indigo
you had a suggestion and it was sort of
accelerated
on your launching pad but what if the
launching pad is endogenous it's a
chemical reaction that you experience
every night when you go to sleep and
dream because in a lucid dream state you
can make a suggestion and your brain
might sort of meander along that path
and provide provide you with what you
sought to see
well i think there are a lot of
similarities between
some forms of hallucination and dreaming
though
for the majority of people who seem
incapable of lucid dreaming
dreaming is all enveloping you have
a dream in consciousness and no
consciousness outside it you can't say
the time is is 9 30 and i'm i'm dreaming
of whatever
with a hallucination your critical
consciousness
is there
there are some forms of
hallucination which are very much
like dreaming you especially have this
with temporal lobe seizures
where you are transported to a place and
time or to contact with other people you
you have a
you go back into your past
either a real pastor
or or a fantasy past
whichever
um
in the charles bonnet types of
hallucination you never recognize
if you see a face you don't recognize it
if you see a landscape you don't
recognize it
it's that that's very far from
memory or imagination and the temporal
lobe ones
are beginning to approach
fantasy and dream and
i think there's
there are a lot of parallels
i i wish i could say more but i i will
say that dreaming like schizophrenic
hallucination is another vast subject
which i i have
not yet embarked on and since i'm about
to embark on my ninth decade i i better
get a move on
yes yeah but stop slacking off sacks
ladies and gentlemen this has been
fantastic we're going to wrap here we
want to leave time for the book signing
uh out in the hall oliver will be out
there signing uh copies of
hallucinations we want to welcome you
and thank you for participating in this
world science festival science and story
event
there will be other events
and of course
thanks to dr oliver sacks
okay
you